and I went to 10 welcome to this rapid
game on VHS so we've got a full plate or
querido let's do something else
so we're thinking about the post defense
but rather something fluid or time so II
5 the problem with e 5 a little bit is
that after the trade has become somewhat
boring and I don't want to do that in a
video it's not such a bad position at
all the Queen trade but this is a Ted
risky because White has most like f/4g
form in protection in particular g4s
slight issue as g5 is a substantial
threat and black has to play slowish
with h6 and down now stop box a Glock
but I've taken a slight risk here he did
not try to use this smooth water now we
get a regular fleet on defense Bishop c4
is seen mostly
I can also play G 3 or a 4 so it Bishop
C fires the most own most popular choice
look
most likes a main idea is to set up a
wall of pawns like c 6a 6b 5 would be
nice to get in or c6 b 6a 6b 5 something
like that in some cases you get
something that looks a little bit if you
just look at the black sign looks a
little bit like they're closed with your
past
it's to mute the microphone is this them
okay so coffee time what are you doing
and this is not supposed to work which
doesn't mean like heck winning at okay
so the first step is now to decide where
to go with the King I can okay I cannot
go to have eight ninety six or eight
again 96 I'm losing the Queen but should
I go to g8 or g6
96
I had on some some weird lines I have
some kind of memory here I think between
kingi 896 squeee 897 26 and then they
cannot take the look because of cream g2
rook f1 takes on ad for 2495 so
something like that is what I remember I
looked at looked I looked at the
Philidor defense I know it's been ages
there's also some line where King g6 is
possible okay I'm going for this
spending more time looks a little bit
that looks a little bit much and by the
way by the way if you look at all the if
you watch all the games in succession
and I did not lose rating points from my
last game because him see okay I got
refunded because of cheating during the
game it didn't occur to me so much that
my opponent could could be a cheater
because he played pretty terribly
actually and then I learned that
blundered everything away
oh it's it's that's an amazing move
hmm Wow
okay M night to be five queen g6 is the
most obvious movie attacking g2 I taking
e4 and if you cancel if I just play c6
what is the problem I mean it looks a
little bit weird but I don't see a
problem I think if he takes on c7 now
I'm just going to take g2 and again if I
was hanging
I'm not losing the rook is the thing I
mean if he takes it
I still have because you piayed if he
takes on c7 I mean I can use the arrows
so any capture I so can just move the
rook away and at the moment I'm
attacking before and g2 so he has to
careful I guess castling looks almost
forced
me too it's not a poignant that you can
just give up Wow am i overlooking here I
don't quite get it I'll just take this
look everyone is forced
even b6 comes into consideration like
Knight takes rook Bishop a6 I can also
take you for but Bishop III looks
alright when I can I can play Queenie
for Bishop b3 e txt for forcing further
trades but just UPA again what is the
thing I never we're looking something
I'm a little bit irritated because this
is it just looks like it doesn't work at
all for white
she set up fine yeah it looks fine we
should be three and so he definitely
wants to M castlelong
and if he takes we have yes a 7-under
tab so v6 looks like a normal move can
also take I don't know it looks somewhat
wrong and it's that a way to immediately
force force the Meta Knight f8 9 f8 9 xf
8 Bishop h3 it looks like a good idea
night f8d takes e5 I look so that it
looks a little bit annoying even though
I can take you six and shove 86 a bishop
a seven don't don't believe in it I mean
I also have 95 and so on
9f hd5 I can also play Bishop takes c6
threatening Bishop c4 Knight things not
that it's okay so d5 I think I can take
with both 96 or Bishop e6 where I think
I will go P should be 6th Bishop e6 96
96 c5 takes f6 Bishop f6 Queen d5 it's
actually a little bit annoying
hmm okay so maybe de 596 rather de 596
Bishop a7 like 95 to go for some
counter-attack yeah we'll see what is
what is doing hi edges don't believe
that de 5 words maybe the easiest is
actually D 5 D 5 Bishop 1/7 it should be
6
you cannot take on be a Jew - Bishop c4
I think nobody they return some material
right now what the N type appears up at
the slide
D is five now that's it's a totally
funny
do you have I also have Crete xe4 check
you ship a seven a tiki six with the
bishop
I'm currently a piece out for porn I
mean so what else can he do if he takes
on f8 I play Bishop h3 okay that move I
did not consider so I can go on we
should reform would be one idea should
before I it's not bad he please say he
has to move the Queen elect to to d3
[Music]
there is something something better in
nigeria is check on d5
this is not good so
you see threatening anything at all I
don't see Bishop h3 even looks good
it seems a tad lame though I mean I can
even play each section
for there are so many good-looking moves
you kind of lose track a little bit so
the night is attacked and it does not
really have all that many squares Bishop
takes a seven I take g5 we should be
eight Bishop age three and then winning
this back at the end I should be a piece
up it doesn't have a logical Scratchy go
trim just don't see it
still suffering a little bit from
insomnia due to the high temperatures
I'm not as fresh as I would like to be
95 I'm going to take the knight on d5 I
think 97 King f7 and that's perfect King
and save and I have Bishop f3 coming I
don't see a move on slim Knight f3 the
special key form I think that's this
line with the capture on f7 just doesn't
work there is a different version of
this with Knight g5 then Bishop f7 and
then 96 they do think a bit more
interesting but I could be wrong it's
been in a really long time since I
checked this okay so here I take g5
Bishop a7 Bishop h3 did I miss count all
that nice to the PISA at the end I might
not have any pause left that could be a
problem
okay this move I did not look at all
so my look is a checked yeah so Bishop
age three is almost made threat but you
are castled long
Kevin difficult really difficult there
are some ways you just play for what
strong attack and like Bishop g4 Queen
takes b8 and then just attack to take
for an exchange became I can also just
lift the rock but then you will cancel
and this is not really all that nice is
there anything that he threatens here
besides taking the rook
you
I don't I don't want to play passively
maybe this is a wrong a day a real
completely wrong idea but I don't want
to play a passive more Bishop g4 will be
eight
that keeps the skin in the middle maybe
96 and 87 but this material was not even
all that bad
the should be four and ig6 who had
something like in very easily screw up
I also don't want to allow him to castle
it's really something I don't want I
mean currently my Kingfield save okay
I'm going for it what I don't know is
after Queen eight which looks forced if
I play Knight g6
which was my intention or and I can do
something else
Queen b8 Queen f3 I think and he plays
on kinky - and I'm not sure how I'm
conditioning all this maybe I cannot
punish him 94 King c1 them I don't think
that that works immediately
and see anything else he can always
escape by a did you see one so maybe in
Queen Bee 896 I just have to do to get
the material and then attack from there
that also allows whoopty eight get the
rook into the game
yeah wonder can you really do something
he does not take that's pretty amazing
so 27 is his threat
okay so queen is 7 kingi 6 and then what
it is made but if I click afore it's not
made the audience is chicken
okay let's place all to remove probably
we'll just take yeah five and then
castle after you take a five
unfortunately I cannot just play
ninety-seven due to Queenie six probably
wookie aid he can Castle long it's it's
really a bit bit awful
so he grabs it here I was thinking just
creamy form when you give any cannot
cash flow cannot cancel again and I'm
kind of ok material-wise 96 metaphor is
the immediate idea look you won probably
96 with the tempo is just around the
corner
look G wanna have G form on ninety-six
actually a 96 with the temple
where's the queen going to c3
that looks pretty good has to go to c3
almost off 94 now jinx
oh yeah
and have to go here but now threatening
on c2 and on f3 and castles fields to
292 and rook c8 so ton of things or
something else
don't don't don't think so let's okay
there was a pretty chaotic game it's not
over yet but almost um
should rent a medium or as possible on
g7 and route d8 blunders it not look so
good now just take this with chick yeah
and he resides yeah I'm kind of curious
about all this I feel like something's
going
let's see what their what the engine
gives so I think this line isn't great
really this Bishop of 79 the exhaust
chick yeah I wasn't quite sure if maybe
the screams King g6m but that that looks
far more normal them 96 creamy and yeah
and four now 95 I was thinking who the
heck is stinger done with saying okay so
this is what why I expected
yeah it now may be careful Sam
I think you cannot take this is this
missus wrong I think like is having all
the fun and free though my the engine
doesn't student have a really clear and
valuation here
doesn't seem to y'all that can and this
is probably what he has to do
95 looks strange
so we'll see six yeah okay with this is
the most obvious move and now night yeah
Castle Jenny castles this this is folly
what you should do even though this is
it's not going to work objectively it's
just one pawn for the peace and those
nights that kind of they don't really
call in aid all that well but he took
them down to Queen G - it's already
initial 9f AHL loop the aid still should
be very good one side should be 3 and 9
f8 I said one of the top choices yes
well I'm sure in this position if
there's something else but it looks good
D takes a 96 also works I figured that
this should work but g5 was easier and
95 I didn't think about but now this I
think this was my intention because here
I'm winning it's not able to defend us
not just as broken IG v h6 is best best
it seems and here the check I'm just
taking so this was right Queen b6 and
our Bishop age 3 is actually stronger
yeah I did not you know I did not like
that you can cancel long and okay either
peace out but I did you know I did not
see that I have this one that looks very
good I didn't see 96 so my Bishop G form
is not all that bad
I think yeah and here I would have
played 96 which is not the best so Queen
f3 is indeed correct yeah I didn't quite
see a solution after this either check
have caught a check first and then he
has to go here and then 94 I am and here
black is going for them for the maid
well I very likely I would have played
1960 Anders Photoshop and this isn't
isn't as clear I will see in this
position and I thought I'm better which
it seems to be true according to the
computer but the other line was even
more forcing and I saw that I can take
you for now and everything else fails
look h3
Wow
you
I'm threatening 23 now here thanks
creepy for a while and so that was also
strong my idea would have probably won
but it is not I know it you know it goes
down so 96 isn't a terrible it's also -5
so my ad the right-hand stem and yeah
this is what you did and at the end I
just took it and it's the best solution
and yeah let's just attacking lawn
castles what are Queen c7 and now
cancels long yeah okay 96 Maki that's
also fantastic for like okay will G 1
this is a Tekken size is decisive
now let's double question mark I mean it
is totally lost anyway cold
I didn't even play the quickest way but
if you can pick up all the pieces enough
yeah so the Phyllida was not not such a
bad opening since I think it's quite
sometimes underrated and Bishop
ascendant it's not probably not that
great but as we had seen it it's not
like winning there are some worki
working lands possible alright thanks
for watching